[bike engine roaring]
[tires screeching]
To go that fast with that much lean angle,
that's basically an immediate crash.
Hi, my name's Casey Stoner.
I'm a former MotoGP world champion.
In my career, I managed to win
two MotoGP world championships.
Today, we're looking at
motorcycle scenes from movies
and judging how real they are.
Motorcycle with one hand
isn't difficult at all,
but with your opposite
hand, it is very difficult.
As soon as you look around or look back,
quite often you veer offline.
And there's people that can
ride and do wheel stands
and stoppies while riding
backwards and sidesaddle
and all that sort of other thing,
but it takes a heck of a lot of practice,
and it's not at those speeds
while trying to sword fight.
Yeah, there's not a whole
lot of realism in that one.
Trying to get something through a wheel
when it's spinning that
fast is nearly impossible.
If anything happens to the back wheel,
it certainly doesn't cause
the front to come up and go.
Now, if something gets
lodged in the front wheel,
that will happen.
The back will come up
and go over the front.
It was quite realistic.
Wet white lines,
the way we explain it in
racing, it's like ice.
As soon as you come across a white line
that's not painted with a special grip,
it's literally just,
as soon as you touch it,
you're pretty much gone.
If you know you're going to crash
or you know you're going to hit something,
a lot of the time, the best way
is either just to lay the bike down,
because a low side or a front-end lose,
there's going to be a
lot less complications.
When you have a high side,
which is when you lose the rear end
and then it creates grip again
and it flicks you over the high
and basically sends you up in the air.
So when you go, what
goes up must come down,
and it's a lot more painful,
and I definitely had a little
more experience than I'd like.
I would say probably a 2.
Eyes would be watering, that's for sure.
The no-helmet thing would be
probably the most difficult aspect.
Any little bits of dust,
of rock flicking up off a car,
off the bike in front,
almost impossible, a lot
of the stuff he does.
We do that basically to get a feeling
of where the ground is.
It gives us an understanding
of where our lean angles
are and things like that.
Now, without a knee slider,
it's doing very little,
other than to take a bit of skin off.
I've seen bikes explode.
As these are the kind
of standard road bikes,
the temperatures are so high,
especially around the head of the exhaust,
that it really can ignite quite a lot.
So, the shifting is something
to be brought up a little.
You don't need to do a clutch.
That's a very, very old system
to basically ease the bike
in a little bit easier
and a little bit smoother into gear.
Unless you're going back
gears going into a corner,
you don't need to use the clutch.
On modern bikes these days,
we have something called
a quickshifter now.
So it cuts the power to
the engine for a second,
allows the bike to reduce
a little bit of torque
so that the gear can select
and then they can keep going.
The crash was pretty fine.
You know, losing the front
end in that situation,
I guarantee he would have a
little bit of meat missing
down the side of his body.
As soon as you touch tarmac,
it likes to rip apart whatever you've got,
even with leathers on.
But overall, because he slid
onto the gravel as well,
it would have been a little softer
than sliding the whole way on tarmac.
I'd probably rate this scene around an 8.
Of course. There's
always a key in the bike.
You know, they go and
get on and just start it,
and off it goes.
I mean, going up stairs on a bike
realistically isn't very hard at all.
Even for myself, who's not
a technical rider like this.
They actually have that as part of a race,
going up them and down them,
and they're actually
racing through the streets.
Riding across the top of that small gap
would have been the most difficult
part of that whole scene.
As easy as it seems, when
you're going at that speed,
one little mistake can
be quite catastrophic.
So getting those gaps
would have been definitely
a little bit tricky at those speeds.
You know, they were doing
a very, very good job
on that scene.
It's not that hard to
do those sort of drops.
Actually, the faster you
go, the better it is.
The slower you go, the more
straight down you sort of go.
But you come down and you land flat
from too high of a point,
you can break your
wrists, break your ankles.
If you hit the seat as well,
people have broken their backs and things,
so it can be quite tricky.
You know, those drops were realistic,
you can do that,
but, yeah, it starts
getting bigger than that,
then some injuries start to happen.
It would probably be a 9.
Pretty incredible what
people can do on bikes,
especially these days. They
just keep pushing the limits.
They actually had a key this time!
They got it right with that.
They needed a key to start the bike.
Jumping off the truck
might've been possible
with a motocross bike or an off-road bike,
but with a road bike
with two people on it,
as soon as they landed,
it just would have bounced them
and high sided or something.
That basically is nearly
impossible for that to happen.
The burnout, turning around,
yes, that's possible
the way they were just
sitting there and doing it.
Especially with two people on board,
you've got a lot of
weight over the rear tire.
That's quite hard to then
get it to spin around.
A lot of the whole burnouts
and then taking off from there
basically being like a boost,
that's not the case.
It's a negative for us.
If you've ever seen somebody do burnouts
and you have a look at
that tire afterwards,
there's a big flat part of the tire,
because you've basically just
melted the rubber off it.
And we don't want it flat.
We need to keep a round surface.
With cars, you kind of do
need to do a burnout sometimes
to try and heat the tire through.
[siren wailing]
A lot of movies get this wrong,
but this one in particular,
is the fact that cars can
just catch them so quickly.
There's very few supercars
that can go as quick as what bikes can.
Especially a Ducati.
You know, that's top of
the line at the time.
Bikes have acceleration that's incredible.
You know, it's basically
a 160-, 180-kilo bike
for 200-plus horsepower.
The ratio is extreme.
And when they've got cars
that can just zoom right up to them,
that's probably the most unrealistic part.
The ride into the traffic and
everything at the beginning
wasn't too bad.
I think with two people
on it's unrealistic.
You can't change direction that quickly.
Road bikes, the faster you go,
the harder it is to change direction.
If they're going at the
speeds that are implied,
those maneuvers just aren't possible.
The stunt riders,
they've got to have cars
coming along with them,
so they're restricted to
what speed they can do.
And when they're going slower,
it's actually quite hard to have good form
as if you were doing those fast scenes.
So it's a very tricky thing to do.
And that's why I was impressed
with the "Mission: Impossible,"
because you're actually able to see
they've got quite good form
all through that scene.
They've got quite good styles
and everything like that.
So I would rate this a 3 or a 4 again.
The fact that they had a key,
I really liked that aspect.
Harleys in general are a
little difficult to ride.
Everything's so low-slung,
and it's quite actually hard
to get them to corner
at the best of times.
Harleys actually can have
quite a lot of horsepower.
I mean, they're incredible machines.
As soon as you go down through
any kind of dip or curve,
it's not going to like it.
There's no way a big bike like that
wouldn't just land and
go into a ton of pieces.
And if it was real, I mean,
I don't think they'd have
much of a back left, so.
That's quite hard for me
to see actually happening.
A big, heavy bike like that
landing from that sort of drop,
only a dirt bike could make that drop,
and it's still going to hurt a bit.
I would say
3, 4 again.
There's parts of it that
were realistic enough.
Drifting on a motorcycle,
on a road bike's definitely possible.
To go that fast with that much lean angle,
that's basically an immediate
crash at those sort of speeds.
And, for me, at that angle
was just sort of not possible.
There's going to be no more grip,
and the bike will go
away from underneath you.
There's lots of elements.
Again, we're talking about
on the street as well.
So if it was on a racetrack,
you got consistent grip
levels, et cetera, et cetera.
But this is the first time
seeing it on a street.
There's oil spills, all that.
It's going to be very difficult to manage
and judge those situations.
So I would say that's nearly impossible.
That's not a problem to do
that and create a stoppie.
The distance that she did it in, though,
was probably unrealistic,
because to do a stoppie
actually makes you stop slower.
If you've got the rear wheel, let's say,
a foot off the ground, that's not too bad.
That's at about your breaking limit,
because there's a certain
force and angle and everything.
As soon as you start going too far,
then that force is
carrying you over the top.
For someone to stop that
quick with a stoppie,
it's not realistic.
It's electric bike, so
they don't have clutches.
Just use the throttle
with an electric bike.
Which, again, would probably
make the burnout that she did
quite difficult as well.
I would say, again, 3, 4 mark.
Wai Lin: Give me that!
Clutch, clutch, clutch!
Turn right.
No, left.
Who's driving?
Riding with two people
doing something different
is nearly impossible.
It'd be easier to ride one-handed
than it would be to ride
with two people like that.
For two people to just jump on
and one use the clutch
and the left handlebar
and one use the throttle
and brake on the right,
unless you've practiced day
in, day out with someone,
to do something like that's,
you know, that's impossible.
[bike engine buzzes]
The noise of this bike,
there's no way a big bike like that's
going to be that quiet.
It sounded very much like a scooter.
So many scenes you'll see
of two-strokes that
sound like a four-stroke.
They just, you know, they
haven't quite got it right.
And this one almost sounds like
a scooter that's taking off.
You know, it certainly
doesn't sound like a Harley
or that big bike that
they're actually riding.
Bond: Hold on!
Doing a wheelie like that on that bike is,
it's not impossible.
Big, heavy bike like that,
you're going to struggle
to really get the power.
It's long, and the balance
point's very, very,
it's quite bad on those sort of bikes.
You know, they're made
to stay on the ground.
They're not made to get the
front wheel in the air. So.
I've seen people that can
wheelie just about anything,
but, yeah, I would say, again,
that's a very, very low
probability to be able to do that.
Wheelies do not help you go faster.
The amount of times I see them
drop back a couple of gears
and [makes revving noise]
and then chuck a wheelie
and all of a sudden they're flying along.
It's not faster.
All of your weight then is going up.
It's the same with the stoppie scene.
If you've got your weight going down,
it's wanting to overtake you.
But with a wheelie up
here, you can't accelerate.
You can't get going, because basically
the bike wants to keep
going the other way.
So wheelies, especially
in racing, is our enemy.
Occasionally, you can
come up and control it,
but it has to be no more than
6, 8 inches off the ground.
And that's where you find
that sort of balance point.
You get any further than that,
it wants to start overtaking you,
and then you have to
start backing off, so.
Unless you're throwing a wheelie,
I guess, to stop some bullets hitting you,
as we've seen in quite a few,
yeah, there's no way
wheelies are helping you out.
Of course the jump is impossible,
and just going through
a roof and surviving it
and not breaking your
backs on just the impact.
That one was very, very
difficult to see the realism in.
And I'd probably go a 1 or a 2.
I know the rider who actually did that
and ridden with him personally
and know that everything's
possible that's in that movie.
So, you know, there's nothing
unrealistic for me there.
The jump that he made up the
wall is definitely possible.
He had, you know, small amount
of ramp there from the curb.
The key to getting up heights like that,
it's all loading the
body, loading the bike,
loading the tires and suspension
all at the right moment.
So they use that little pop, that ramp
for the front end to get that up,
and to get over a wall like that,
you can't just clean jump it,
so basically they're
using their rear tire.
Jumping up as far as they can,
keep the front tire over the top of it,
and then they use their rear
to ride up the last bit.
And then that helps the front clear,
and then they use their
momentum to get over, so.
Everything that he did was 100% real,
so 10 out of 10.
They kept themselves in
a realistic state there,
so I like that one.
Steve McQueen's an absolute legend
and I think did most of his
own stunts ever on a bike
and things like that.
He was just incredible, you know,
there was no special effects
or anything like that.
That was a clean, honest
jump and everything.
Grass isn't too bad
if you've got off-road tires, knobbies.
If they're fresh and have sharp edges,
grass really isn't too bad to ride on.
It gives you a fair bit of grip.
But on the type of bike he
was on, with those tires,
there wouldn't have been
a whole lot of grip.
It was nice to see a couple
little slide-outs there,
things like that, because it was,
you know, lush, green grass.
It ends up being very, very slippery.
But to be honest, quite a lot of fun.
The jump, definitely possible.
Everything plausible.
So, yeah, I'd have to give it a 10.
The sparking boots is something
that they would have made or designed.
It could just be a few screws
that they put around
the edge of the boots.
We started to do a night race in Qatar,
and during the night race,
when I was racing Ducati,
we had quite low foot pegs
the way our bike was
designed and everything.
So during the daytime you
couldn't see it sparking,
but at nighttime, because I
was touching the foot pegs
on one of the corners on the track,
it would spark quite a lot.
It's not too difficult to get
some sparks happening at nighttime.
The wheelies were all possible.
The stoppies were possible.
It's all more than plausible.
It's all stuff I can do myself,
so if I can do it,
definitely there's some people out there
that can do a heck of
a lot more than that.
The one thing that I probably couldn't do
was when he did the handstand,
they only used the clutch when
they were going back gears.
They weren't going too fast.
Doing everything in every
maneuver they did was plausible.
Everything's realistic there.
I'd have to say, yeah, 10 out of 10.
If you enjoyed this video,
click here to watch another one.